pour
[Musique]
voir les enfants poros
tu as toujours mal à l'estomac nounours
oui potes oh ça t'apprendra à manger
trop de sucreries mais de petits amis
vont me soigner je descends les voir bon
l'échelle
[Musique]
de popopopop
louis
nicollin
[Musique]
du malade de cacher comme ça
je suis et je
[Musique]
lui dirai grand père
bossait
mais avoue une visite une visite à la
[Musique]
montée
non monsieur je ne sais pas je suis une
tête de mickaël hay par e mail je suis
enchanté monsieur
il n'entend pas très bien votre gros
pain six mentions
j'entendrai bien mais je ne chante pas
nounours est très contente de te
connaître péter
[Musique]
chanter
asseyez-vous
comprendre bien quelque chose merci
monsieur mais j'ai mal à l'estomac vous
prendrez bien
une petite coupe d'un call me ferait le
plus grand bien
vous n'y pensez pas cette pauvre petite
ambre savez d'une infusion pour ton ami
une institution c'est pour très bon non
merci gros père
[Musique]
tu vois là ne nous
donnons
ci nombreux papas se sache et en os
de la camomille
que londres
et en quoi non merci ni l'état je vais
m'en aller
[Musique]
il est bizarre ce grand-père
dessous d'une dépense ou encore un peu
de la fusion une
petite goutte venons au grand père j'ai
bien envie de lui tirer les moustaches
oleko qu'un internement ils m'ont encore
fait une blague
nounours tu es un btan et tu as du tout
cette institution
je n'ai plus mal à l'estomac tu vois
déjà fusion c'est excellent pour la
santé et maintenant tu n'as plus mal
oui c'est vrai hall ont dormi vite sur
petits car nos maux
la
gta le
haut nous
[Musique]
alors nounours était maux d'estomac
nicolas et pimprenelle mon curie patron
le cher petit en route nounours bonne
nuit des enfants allez vite vous coucher
comme nicolas et pimprenelle une fête de
pur
[Musique]
oh
vous
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]